Olá a todos. pessoal, aqui quem fala é o Dark.
e sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo.
e bom o que vai acontecer hoje, é o seguinte.
À uns tempo eu vi um vídeo que eu curti pra caramba.
que é do
canal Inutilismo, acho que é assim
basicamente, ele irrita um player de League of Legends.
e eu tipo, me acabei de rir com aquela cena.
e hoje o que eu vou fazer, é mais ou menos a mesma coisa.
vai... eu vou copiar mesmo
bora, vamos lá
(susurro) ele vai começar agora o jogo, eu acho
o pc dele é tão podre que nem roda as imagens (risada)
heeelooooooouuu (oláaaaaaaaaa)
então, o que está fazendo?
estou jogando lol
Quem que é este champion (campeão) aqui?
É o Fizz
Este aqui?
olha aí cara, não está vendo? quer que eu jogue no seu pc?
(hahhahhahha)
o meu pelo meno aguenta rodar lol.
olha essa bolacha, você nem me ofereceu.
olha só!
deixa de ser chato, man
esse copo é de quem?
é que champion?
É a Kalista
É quem a Kalista? Ela é boa?
Foda-se
Ó, vou te bater
O que a poção faz?
se você usar, ela recupera a sua vida.
E por que que o teu nome é um nome fixe?
É caseiro, o vídeo
Tá bem, tá bem
Eu posso apontar a câmara assim?
Olha aí, puto
Isso é o que é? Ranked?
É normal?
Por que tás a falar com as pessoas?
Para, fica quieto!
Mas por quê? Por quê?
Fica quieto!
Olha aí, man!
Faltam 30 segundos
Isto é 7.1, estes fones?
Fica quieto! Vai quebrar os fones!
É para jogar LOL?
Puto, é sério. Fica quieto. Já não tou a brincar, caralho. Olha aí
Foda-se
Por que que o teu pc tem fita cola?
Para, para!
Jogas LOL com o comando?
Puto, para... Não, não jogo
Puto, para, sério. Para, puto, é sério
Vai lá pra
Vai lá pra fora
tás num arbusto!
tás num arbusto! Ah já saiste do arbusto
isto é minions?
ensinas-me a jogar lol?
tu não gostas de jogar lol
porque jogas com um pente?
para puto
para, ja disse para ir la para fora
este pente é adc
ah é adc
sabes o que é magical
esta banana é magical
foda-se
Eu to falando sério mesmo, puto, olha isso
isso é ranked
Esta gravando puto, sai daqui
Aguenta jogar lol
AGUENTA JOGAR LOL!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Sabia que os homens das obras também jogam lol?
Aguenta jogar lol
Na sua vez de jogar vai estar fudido comigo
Puto eu não estou brincando cara!
HAHA
Compra bota, esta descalço
Aaa, ta devagar(slow) Vais morrer
Vai morrer?
Será que você vai morrer?
vai morrer?
hum hum hum
eeee Já vi um cara fazer isso na net
Mas eu não copio youtubers
foda-se!
(GRITOS)
Mas o estudio não é pra jogar lol
jogador profissional nao usa fone
tem que usar razer!
usa razer.
7.1 pra jogar lol
esta a usar o fone?
isto tens que estar ligado ao pc
porque o teu pc tem fita cola?
posso desligar aqui?
só uma vez!
eu to em ranked puto
eu to em ranked
foda-se puto
adeus!
olha mas tu nao vai jogar lol?
só o windows 8 é que aceita o lol?
e a cricita da tua mãe,
porque que esta coçando a cabeça?
an?
queeee
outra vez jogando lol
Miguel Monteiro
puto é serio
olha o trynda puto 5x0 puto
ta feedado
seu feeder
tu alimenta as outras pessoas?
porque? porque é miguel?
puto é serio nao me tocas puto
NAO ME TOCAS !
TURBULENCIA
o que tás a dizer as pessoas?
" eu tenho que carregar uma mochila nas minhas costas "
esta fazendo queixas as pessoas?
seu feeder
isso nao é desculpa
seu podre
(GRITANDO)
(grito)morreu
este mouse é da razer?
tens descarregar aqui nesta...
PARA PARA PUTO
PARA PUTO
olha, foda-se
MORREU!
fdp
(batida)
agora você me chateou
(grito) (barulho de objetos sendo jogados)
ó desculpa puto, desculpa
pode jogar lol
eu acho que vamos ter aqui muito problema de net
o que que é isto aqui que eu tirei?
ta aqui um fio solto
desculpa
puto fica quieto puto
mas porque que tu nao jogas lol de casaco?
é mais confortavel
mas tem mais armadura
o que esta fazendo?
sabes tocar piano?
olha isso ó como é que esta o meu cotovelo
esta jogando outra vez amigo? (musica de fundo)